esta es una captura de pantalla de 10
moss es una calculadora gráfica en línea
lo que vamos a hacer es usarla para
entender cómo podemos escalar funciones
y te invito a que vayas a des molí lo
pruebes por tu cuenta ya sea durante
este vídeo o después comencemos con una
función agradable e interesante
digamos que fx es igual al valor
absoluto de x eso es bastante sencillo
ahora intentemos crear una versión a
escala de fx así que podríamos decir que
x es igual a bueno voy a empezar con el
valor absoluto de x que es lo mismo que
fx de modo que trazaremos la gráfica de
egb x justo encima de f
pero ahora multiplicamos por una
constante multiplicamos por 2 observen
la diferencia entre x y fx y puedes ver
que x es sólo 2 veces
fx de hecho podemos escribirlo de esta
manera podemos escribir gx es igual a 2
por fx y llegamos a exactamente a lo
mismo pero puedes ver que a medida que
nuestra x aumenta
de x aumenta dos veces más rápido al
menos para las x positivas en el lado
derecho y en realidad a medida que x
disminuye gx también aumenta el doble de
rápido por lo que es sólo una
coincidencia que tenemos un 2 aquí y
aumento dos veces más rápido bueno
pongamos un 3 aquí ahora parece que está
aumentando tres veces más rápido y lo
hace en ambas direcciones y ahora qué
pasa si ponemos 0.5 aquí 0.5 bueno ahora
parece que está aumentando la mitad de
rápido y eso tiene sentido porque
estamos multiplicando estamos escalando
la cantidad de nuestra fx así que antes
cuando x era igual a 1 llegamos a 1 pero
ahora cuando x es igual a 1 solo
llegamos a la mitad antes cuando x era
igual a 5 llegamos a 5
ahora cuando x es igual a 5 sólo
llegamos a 2.5 de modo que estamos
aumentando a la mitad de la rapidez o
tenemos la mitad de la pendiente ahora
una pregunta interesante es pensar en lo
que sucede
y en lugar de tener sólo un valor
absoluto de x digamos que tenemos una
intersección con el eje distinta de cero
digamos no sé más 6
así que fíjense que cuando cambiemos
esta constante al frente no sólo cambia
la pendiente sino que cambia la
intersección en ye porque estamos
multiplicando esta expresión entera por
0.5 de modo que si lo multiplicas por 1
estamos nuevamente en donde llegamos
antes y ahora si lo multiplicamos por 2
esto debería aumentar la intersección en
ye porque recuerden que estamos
multiplicando estos dos términos por 2 y
vemos que no sólo se duplica la
pendiente sino que también aumenta la
intersección en y si ponemos 0.5 no sólo
disminuye la pendiente en un factor de
la mitad o supongo que podrías decir
multiplicar la pendiente por un medio
sino que también hizo que nuestra
intersección fuera de la mitad de lo que
era antes y podemos ver esto de manera
más general si ponemos una constante
general aquí y podemos agregar un
control deslizante y déjenme hacer que
la constante vaya de 0 a 10
con un paso de 0.05 esa es la cantidad
que aumenta cada vez que cambias el
deslizador fíjense cuando aumentamos
nuestra constante no sólo nos estamos
volviendo más angostos porque la
magnitud de la pendiente está haciendo
escalada sino que nuestra intersección
en y aumenta y luego a medida que
disminuye nuestra intersección en ye se
reduce y nuestra pendiente se reduce
ahora esa es una forma en que podríamos
escalar una función pero qué pasa si en
lugar de multiplicar toda nuestra
función por una suma constante en lugar
de eso simplemente reemplazamos la equis
con una constante por equis entonces en
lugar de k por fx qué pasa si ponemos
fbk por equis otra forma de pensar en
eso es que x ahora es igual al valor
absoluto de k x + 6 que crees que va a
pasar pausa este vídeo y piénsalo ahora
cuando aumentamos k observen que no
tiene impacto en nuestra intersección n
porque no está escalando la intersección
en p
tiene un impacto en la pendiente cuando
k va de 1 a 2 una vez más estamos
aumentando el doble de rápido y luego
cuando k pasa de 1 a la mitad
ahora estamos aumentando la mitad de
rápido ahora esto es con una función de
valor absoluto que pasa si lo hacemos
con un tipo diferente de función digamos
que lo hacemos con una función
cuadrática 2 - x al cuadrado
dejen de desplazarme un poco hacia abajo
puedes ver que cuando k es igual a 1
estos son iguales y si aumentamos
nuestra k digamos que aumentamos nuestra
cara a 2
observen que nuestra parábola está
disminuyendo en este caso a medida que
avanzamos más y más desde cero a un
ritmo más rápido eso es porque lo que
habrías visto en x igualados ahora lo
estás viendo con x igual a 1 porque lo
estás multiplicando por 2 de modo que si
vamos entre 0 y 1 fíjense que a ambos
lados de 0 nuestra parábola está
disminuyendo a un ritmo menor es una
taza cambiante pero es una taza
cambiante más baja
supongo que podríamos decirlo así y
también podríamos intentar ver qué pasa
con nuestra parábola aquí si en lugar de
poner acá x una vez más ponemos la cara
al frente qué va a pasar y fíjense que
está cambiando no sólo qué tan rápido
está cambiando la curva en diferentes
puntos sino que también está cambiando
la intersección en ye porque ahora
estamos escalando esa intersección en y
así que los dejaré allí esto es sólo el
comienzo acerca de escalar funciones
realmente quiero que desarrollen un
sentido intuitivo de lo que está pasando
aquí y que en realidad piensen
matemáticamente porque tiene sentido
vea decimos y juega contigo mismo y
también prueba otros tipos de funciones
para ver qué sucede